how did you meet your wife I don't know
this story oh well we met online not on
tinder or anything like that we we have
friends in common and she's friends with
this actress Martha Plimpton
yeah I'm a goonie yes when Martha
Plimpton has she must love it that
that's a producer is my friend Martha oh
[Music]
it's on her business it is honored all
right guard yeah but she has these
salons where she gets like friends
together different people and has a big
dinner and they she watch it so she
invited Meredith and I we knew of each
other but we never met each other and so
she invited both of us at the last
minute I couldn't go I was travelling or
something so Meredith sent me a Facebook
message saying oh you missed some
amazing lasagna last night and then we
just started talking on fitness that was
on February 28th and we've talked every
night we didn't meet face to face until
May 20th yeah that's very old fat it is
very old fashioned every night you were
writing letters to each other yeah
villages although I don't think the
old-fashioned letters had emojis and you
know like weird winking Devils and yeah
yeah but we yeah every single night we
would just we with starting at 9 o'clock
like Alice my daughter would go to bed
and then I would just start texting with
for like hours every night and then we
met face to face May 20th and it was
like we had known each other forever and
then we got I we got engaged on July 4th
we got married on November 4th and we
are getting divorced February then on
the next day we can start texting again
you've really got this figure so mapped
out
you